hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes fine
entertainment cakes it in mud throws it
into a pit and makes it compete for our
Amusement it's not just a concept it's
our sacred code kind of like how those
Predator folk are united in their
favorite pastime hunting people for
sport I mean they also hunt Xenomorphs
wolves Sasquatches anything with a pulse
and a healthy thirst for a good fight
and now I really want to see predators
take on Sasquatches but them quaches are
gonna have their hands full especially
if they're dueling against the Predators
that this Century has blessed us with on
the big and small screen it's 2010's
Predators taking on 2022's prey right
here on versus audiences around the
globe have been treated to some awesome
Predator films in the current Millennium
you got 2010's Predators which played in
theaters worldwide and prey which snuck
up on all of us in 2022 courtesy of Hulu
yeah they're so good at hunting they
crawled into the TV right under our
noses and no one knew that movie's
happening until like what eight minutes
before it dropped that's some impressive
stealth Predator sure I do know that
there was the predator in 2018 and we
also got a couple of Alien vs Predator
movies but this idea was probably best
suited for the Dark Horse Comics run
me you're ugly
as far as Shane black blast Predator
movie it had its moments but nothing
near as awesome as the two closest
competitors to the OG 1987
Schwarzenegger classic Predator which
still holds up as a tremendous action
sci-fi Adventure a fun trivia nugget for
Van Damme fans and the greatest
handshake in human history you son of a
these predators are no pencil pushers
their warriors hell-bent on taking down
the best game this side of the Galaxy in
one corner we have predators the 2010
Classic in my mind anyway that stars
Adrian Brody Alice Braga and a bunch of
badass extraterrestrial Warriors in the
other corner it's prey starring Amber
mid Thunder Dakota beavers and a bunch
of badass extraterrestrial Warriors or
at least one of them the word
extraterrestrials real mouthful can I
just call them ETS or did that one
irresponsible botanist corner of the
market on the term E.T let's call him
rhesus or something and I like recess
don't get me wrong I love that he drank
a beer right out of the fridge but that
all hiding in the stuffed animals trick
it ain't gonna work on Predators they're
vicious intelligent and have really cool
neon green blood
here's how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two Tomato
Meter slash audience score round three
oh the humanity round four iconic
moments and then we'll do a Wild Card
round that should settle the score once
and for all I know you're yelling at
your TV or your phone streaming device
light bright however you're enjoying
this program I know what you're gonna
say but Mark you sexy SOB how can we
have a box office round if one of the
movies wasn't released in theaters I
have a workaround for that come on now
you trust me by now I'm Mark Ellis I've
been hosting this show since everyone in
the original Predator movie was in
office Arnold and Jesse Ventura became
Governors and I think Carl Weathers
should run for public service in the
galaxy far far away Mandalorian season 3
where we vote Apollo Creed the
chancellor of Tatooine ooh now I want to
see Predators fight a bunch of Mandos
that's a pay-per-view match worth
shelling out 99 bucks for this is the
way
this is the way
this is the way all right last thing
before we get going here I love you all
or at least I like you as a friend I
want to hear from you leave a comment or
hit me up on social media with your take
do you like Predators or pray better one
has a resilient doggie the other has My
Doppelganger Topher Grace it's gonna
come down to the wire it's a battle of
ugly mfers right here right now on
versus Let's Get It On
round one box office all right kids we
know that a big time property like
Predator is capable of bringing in buffo
box office but we have a conundrum here
pray the sort of ancestor to Predator
even though director Dan Trachtenberg
doesn't like to call it a prequel was
the first movie in the franchise to go
direct to a streaming service no bring
it home which is convenient for us at
home but might hurt its chances to win a
round that is all about how much Mania
generated at the multiplex but Uncle
Mark promised y'all a fair fight and
here we go just look at the streaming
numbers and we'll estimate a theatrical
run and how that might have done but
before you get there come take my hand
dear viewer as we stroll down memory
lane and be careful there's a bunch of
traps and et's hiding in the trees no
not the cute kind
Predator opened in the summer of 1987
and would go on to generate and adjust
it for inflation 140 million dollars
domestically that's what you call a hit
the follow-up cleverly titled Predator 2
only not 60 million dollars despite
having some cool moments and taking us
inside their spaceship that's a neat
looking trophy kind of reminds me of
that thing that Sigourney Weaver used to
tangle with both Alien vs Predator
flicks and the Predator each earned well
over 100 million dollars around the
globe proppers to you all so now let's
look at our Fierce competitors today
Predators debuted in the summer of 10
and would go on to him as 127 million
dollars worldwide
I saw an opening day probably the first
showing and definitely got that free
refill on the large popcorn that you get
shout out to that kid Jason who works
the concessions at a theater in Corpus
Christi Texas he went viral for his
trademark corn flip routine you pop off
young Squire us former Movie House
employees salute you
and now we hit prey which dropped on
Hulu in the late summer of 22 and within
a couple of months a normal run for a
theater release it had an estimated 6
million Hulu users give it a whirl that
was a record for a film that debuted on
Hulu and it also set Premiere records
for Star Plus in Latin America and
Disney Star Plus in other territories
see the whole world really wanted more
Predator so let's take that 6 million
people and assume that maybe 4.5 million
of those folks would have left their
couch gotten in their car and or Chopper
and driven slash flown to a local
theater to see it at an average of say
15 bucks a ticket that would equal
almost 70 million dollars but I'm gonna
bump that number up to around 90 million
simply because I really like this movie
a lot and if it had been in theaters a
bigger marketing campaign likely would
have generated more pre-release Buzz as
opposed to the favorable Word of Mouth
it did get after the fact okay so
predators still appears to have The High
Ground Anakin over prey in a close
matchup but we can't leave this round
without telling you what Adrian Brody's
highest grossing film of all time is
right Predators ranks fifth on his
resume of Bo though I'm sure he smells
lovely Sandalwood is my guess
Brody's best-selling theatrical film of
all time is King Kong from 2005 had 550
million dollars ooh and now I want to
see the predators take their ship to
Skull Island if my fan fiction has
anything to say about it could happen
Predators gets the win in round one and
goes up one to nothing
round two Tomato Meter slash audience
score critics and audiences have been
dealing with these pesky otherworldly
Hunters since the 1980s and we've always
been revved up to see the next chapter
but After experiencing each new film did
it hold up to that very first one that's
where this round is gonna figure out and
living up to Predator is a tall order no
that wasn't a burn on Jean-Claude Van
Damme and his stature that's average for
an adult male but was a wee bit
diminutive to be a predator you know
it's a shame this used to be such nice
part of Don by the by 1987's Predator is
beloved by both movie reviewers and
goers that Venn diagram does overlap
it's 80 on the Tomato Meter and 87 on
the audience score so yeah that bar is
set quite High I'm sure Van Damme could
jump up and reach it do some pull-ups
but now we zero in on our combatants
here today Predators is fresh on the
Tomato Meter at 65 percent with a Critic
consensus that reads after a string of
subpar sequels this bloody action-packed
reboot takes the Predator franchise back
to its testosterone fueled roots and boy
is that accurate this 2010 movie was the
first to be fresh since the OG
knock knock P2 landed at 31 AVP hit just
22 percent and Requiem thunded down to
12 but there are some sweet fight scenes
in there that's impressive work for
Predators as it came out just three
years after Requiem and brought the
franchise all the way back to delicious
tasting ketchup the Predator sunk back
down below fresh to a rotten 34 percent
with a consensus among critics that
claims it has violence and quips to
spare but it's chaotically Hollow action
adds up to another missed opportunity
for a franchise increasingly defined by
disappointment oh
did all or most of those wacky Predators
humans whoever Die For Nothing once
again we needed a big turnaround in
short order and four years later prey
Hit The Sweet Spot 93 on the Tomato
Meter that's a team record did you did
you want me to give you the critics
consensus it's right there on
rottentomatoes.com super handy and it
reads this rare action thrillers it
spikes adrenaline without skipping on
character development prey is a predator
prequel done right
well there you have it that's a big lead
for prey as we head to the audience
score side where Predators will hope or
pray
for a miracle comeback oh boy oh no is
it it's rotten with the audience with
you the people that tuned in what
happened did I annoy you on the theater
with my incessant cheering and popcorn
crunching look I chew my corn as quiet
as a mouse as silent as an electric
vehicle starting as dormant as Arnold
lying in the mud waiting to sneak attack
in E.T Predators is 52 rotten with the
audience so I can call it fresh adjacent
but I'm not happy with you any of you
you all better behave when you saw prey
and the audience score for that is all
right it's 73 that's fresh but come on
gang I know you're at home get off your
phone pay attention to prey there's a
bear fight for crying out loud
prey is still going to take this round
easily and it's not just against
predators it also defeats every other
movie called prey so there's a prey
movie in 2021 one in 2019 and a 2007
movie called prey starring Bridget
Moynihan none of them involved predators
and they're all rotten two are at 17 and
one is at 13 so way to go pray they're
the one about the hunt happy ETS that
movie wins round two and gets on the
board tying the ball game at one to one
round three oh the humanity is what any
play-by-play announcer would exclaim
watching the events of either film play
out people do not fare particularly well
against predators even if the films do
their best to give us a happy ending
let's find a way off this planet think
about it maybe a couple of us humans
survive if we're lucky but dozens more
meet their maker at the hands of the
Ultimate Warrior that is not a reference
to the wrestler but to be fair that
Ultimate Warrior did win almost 90
percent of his matches and most of those
scripts were likely better than the one
for Alien vs Predator I don't mean knock
those movies but man what an opportunity
we missed it was nice to see Lance
Henriksen again thank you this round
will be won by humans as one Gaggle will
emerge triumphant and score a point for
their film in Predators it's a ragtag
squad of baddies from all over Earth
collected and dunked into a new setting
that feels kind of like a huge
otherworldly paintball course except
these paint pellets
um they really hurt for prey we get to
experience what it's like to be in a
tightly knit indigenous Community way
back in time but in the case of nauru
she's looking to prove her worth as a
hunter as most of her male comrades
doubt her abilities but not sorry the
Wonder Dog
[Music]
all right this round is about the humans
but we have not heard the last from that
wonderful pup what an amazing doggy up
there with Benji Old Yeller Air Bud bb-8
the best of the best movie dogs
Dakota Beaver stars as Toby who is next
in line to lead his people and is the
best warrior going in the village as
such he does see the potential in Sister
Naru where others don't she can hunt
track but can she come up clutch at the
moment of truth with some help from
sorry she can okay I I really love the
dog also shout out to Dane delegro as
the predator in this film what a workout
he went through according to the six
foot nine actor the head cheeses on prey
wanted a leaner more athletic even
balletic version of our villain to
terrorize the local earthlings he lost
25 pounds trained in parkour which is
extremely dangerous never try it
especially if you're as tall as an NBA
power forward but the hard work paid off
his movements echoed out of a feral cat
perhaps a panther and that quickness
serves the Predator well against Tabby
another skilled hunter in wasapi and a
host of brazen French Trappers to be
honest the French folk helped move the
story and it was okay it was kind of
like nutty Lawrence Fishburne and
predators
he shows up disguised as one of the
baddies and then we get to visit his
glacial estate which is a crashed ship
of some sort it's a dwelling for sure
but that whole subplot does make the
film a wee bit long in the tooth what
sharpens the Chompers of predators is
Adrian Brody like we've never seen him
before I knew he was a great actor he
won an Oscar for The Pianist splice was
cool but wow I did not know he had this
level of alpha in him Alice bragas
Isabelle is the perfect compliment to
Brody's Royce they both might prefer to
survive on their own but as the
situation becomes more dire their skills
work hand in hand I got a good feeling
about these two the other combatants ah
they're long-term prognosis ain't good
but we had fun while they were there
Danny Trejo Walton Goggins two-time
Academy Award winner mahersho Ali I
re-watched this movie last week and did
a double take I was like Hey the new
blade is in this too looking good there
boss Louis azawa chang-chan is finally
suited as Hanzo Oleg tacked her off his
brawny brawler Nikolai and of course who
could forget me I mean Topher Grace as
Edwin why is he in this group the kid
from That 70s Show in front of the hit
podcast yes Rotten Tomatoes is wrong is
now one of the fiercest creatures on
Earth well watch the movie plus he
provides Some solid comedic relief
without torpedoing the tension that's a
delicate balance and Topher does it with
grace that is really really poisonous
what sways me towards predators in this
round is the emergence of so many
different looks for a predator we got
your Scouts your super Predators they're
fun Falcon companions oh right I can't
count animals in this round sorry spiky
warthogs and we get the Berserker
Predator they're like Chex Mix it's all
pretty much the same but different
flavors try the Bold one that's my
favorite oh thank God I'm so excited the
tremendous actors like Amber mid Thunder
Dakota beavers and Michelle thrush as
the mother of Naru and tabi gets some
good run and prey but Predators puts its
cast in a more Dynamic setting and gives
them more places to stretch their legs
and employ their personalities plus
Lawrence Fishburne in his weird house
I'm leaning slightly towards predators
in this round they all get the point and
the 2010 flick goes up on its younger
sibling two to one finally found me a
big dog round four iconic moments we
love these kind of alien predator to a
lesser extent Alien versus Predator
movies for many reasons they provide us
with budding Stars established a-listers
professional wrestlers and of course oil
canines but what we're really buzzing
about as we exit the theater or turn the
lights back on at our own house are
those exceptional sequences so thrilling
that they etch themselves in an all-time
science fiction lore the scenes that
make kids believe they could hold their
own with a legendary Hunter species like
a predator and the moments that make us
adults feel like kids again even though
these movies are usually rated R I think
I saw the first Predator when I was like
five and look I turned out okay
if it's memorable parts of a film you
like Predators does not waste any time
it literally starts with badass Adrian
Brody falling from the sky as he's
waking up pulling a shoot just in time
and then he meets some other nerdu wells
in the same situation like Danny Trejo
and then he teams up with Alice Braga
prey also has a formidable punch up top
as the Visage of a spaceship matches
perfectly with the war from nauru's
people both lead characters get tossed
into their new life's purpose rather
immediately and the punch helps both
flicks find their momentum quickly
what's wonderful about Predators is the
title if you look closely you see an S
at the end of that word indicating
plurality as in we got multiple
predators and they come in all sizes
your medium ones a large monster known
as a Berserker and even Lawrence
Fishburne cosplaying as a lethal killing
machine so the real ones don't often I'm
alive that Morpheus always one step
ahead of the game the reveal is just
what we're up against is always a treat
in these films it's like baking cookies
it sounds easy but you can actually mess
it up real easily luckily both Nimrod
and tell and Dan Trachtenberg there is
perspective directors Pillsbury
doughboyed us some tasty reveals Naru
and tabi think they're hunting a lion
until we see some familiar tracks and in
Predators Royce Isabel and the Gang
descend upon a campsite that functions
as both a nice bachelor pad for
Predators you're gonna hang out and get
away from their families for a bit and
it's also a good trap for nosy humans
but what we really care about is the
full force of our beloved antagonists on
display the fight between Hanzo and a
predator is one of my all-time favorites
in franchise history it's well shot
brutal and shows a sense of samurai
warrior respect between two worthy foes
these Predators respect their adversary
and this latest crop of game they
imported from planet Earth lived up to
the task Adrian Brody's Royce ends up
tricking his Foe and employing every
kind of weapon along the way in his
quest to survive it's almost like the
humans who grew up playing the game
mousetrap have the best chance of living
to see another day when battling a
predator lots of traps trickery Tom Fury
you ain't winning a street fight against
these things just as anyone in Predator
2 which does take take place in the
streets of Los Angeles so you got to get
pretty creative I'm here kill me
and it doesn't hurt to borrow some ideas
from previous humans who've had success
against this warlord species even if
technically prey does take place
hundreds of years before the OG Predator
both nauru and then centuries later
Arnold Schwarzenegger's Dutch discovered
that coating themselves in mud disguises
them from the infrared vision that
Predators used to hunt hey look every ET
has a weakness Predators can't see in
mud the signs aliens are allergic to
water and Alf couldn't resist cats
he's quick I'll give him that you kids
understand Alpha references today it's
hard to convey just how huge he was in
the late 80s it was a great show and
he's a first ballot Hollywood Squares
Hall of Famer anywho I give the slight
edge here to pray both films have some
real epic sequences towards their
climaxes and as much as I adore the
variety of showdowns and predators
something about prey getting back down
to muddy Basics really tickled my fancy
Naru sets up a wicked awesome bank shot
that would make Larry Bird smile it's
kind of like when Happy Gilmore sinks
that putt to beat Shooter McGavin and
I'm always down for muddy protagonists
is that mutters that quicksand I can't
tell either way it would kill me and
sadly atreyu's horse in The NeverEnding
Story
I I feel bad I went there but sorry the
Royal dog hero survived this movie and
there was much rejoicing prey should
feel great about that and this breaking
news it's gonna win round four earns
another point and ties the match 2-2 and
now it's time for the Wild Card round
Legacy I know I know you hear the term
Legacy and you say Mark you're so cute
but these two movies aren't old enough
to drive a car how can they have some
meta themselves in the pantheon of great
sci-fi already well they're on their way
to doing that but here I'm looking at
the Legacy as it pertains to Reviving a
Primo name brand property that was
thought to be more abundant until they
injected Fresh Life Innovative new ideas
and blood lots of blood along with some
well-timed Nostalgia into the mix
Predators arrived a few years after AVP
Requiem and it was clear that the big
baddies needed a clean slate so what
better way to erase the chalkboard and
start a new semester than on another
planet
but get this the concept of tossing a
gaggle of fearsome individuals Into The
Fray might be the gift that keeps on
giving every few years we could have
gotten another adventure with a new set
of scary folks battling an even more
frightening species you know how
everyone can't wait to see who gets cast
in the latest murder mystery from Ryan
Johnson people love yelling out names of
viable contenders The Rock Kiki Palmer
The Muppets well Predators share some
DNA as a whodunit simply because these
folks are also coming together under
mysterious circumstances and are finding
out who they can and can't trust for
example Topher Grace's doctor is he
really that or is there gonna be a Twist
and to think I was rooting for him in
the movie win a date with Tad Hamilton
unfortunately Predators loses some
points for not being able to build more
upon that premise as the next movie we
got featuring the ginormous Hunter was
the predator and it was back on Earth it
was a cool team some fun to be had
nowhere near as awesome as Nimrod
Intel's 2010 yard a concept dreamed up
by Robert Rodriguez in the 1990s as
mouthwash for the disc appointing
Predator too
[Music]
all right so predators had a lot of
potential hasn't lived up to it yet
hopefully prey won't fall into the same
trap we took a legendary sci-fi creation
and tossed it into a completely
different time period we could keep
doing that all the live long day the
Predator left something to be desired we
may not have known it would be switching
up the age in which the events take
place but now I want a predator film set
in every Century King Arthur and his
Knights go after one Cleopatra ordering
her Egyptian guards to check out that
weird light in the sky Jesus Christ and
his Apostles could stumble upon a
predator and you could even call that
movie prey too
and let it fly
it writes itself I'm giving you billions
of dollars in ideas Tinseltown make good
on it in terms of honoring the
foundational Predator film from 1987
both these newer takes delivered in
different ways Predators has the reveal
that Isabelle is actually familiar with
the Guatemala incident and recounts the
one Survivor Dutch AKA Arnold aka the
guy so traumatized by that mission he
became a cop to teach his kindergarten
[Music]
who's debrief detailed the monster that
wiped out his team that was such a cool
moment in that movie and you know it
made all of us lifelong fans feel like
we mattered we paid attention all those
years we give it the thumbs up but pray
had that mud bathing thing down to a
science it was certainly a familiar nod
to Duchess maneuver but without feeling
reductionist or repetitive narrow used
the elements around her in order to
survive a couple hundred years later
Dutch would learn the same lesson about
nature after millions of dollars spent
in artillery couldn't pull off the trick
when it comes to medicine and hunting
bloodthirsty ETS sometimes homeopathic
remedies are the best and as much as I
adore Predators the hope that prey gives
all of us Predator honks is too much to
ignore the 2022 film gets the win in the
Wild Card round and thus takes the match
what a tough battle today predators
versus prey I feel like I had to choose
between my own children except I don't
have kids but if I did I'd get them
started on Predator movies early and
pray maybe that'd be the first one I
show them maybe you go in chronological
order according to Canon did any of you
parents do that with Star Wars you show
the little types of prequels first then
solo then Rogue one then the classic
Trilogy and so forth let me know how
that goes and of course hit me up on
social media at Mark ellislive with your
favorite Predator movie ever which time
period should they visit next or should
we head back to a new planet with brand
new campers thank you all for watching
versus until next time I'm your host
Mark Ellis and I ain't got time to bleed
no actually I have a lot of free time